[Music]
oh
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them
touchdown Taylor
t I think that's not working she scored
a touchdown at the
[Music]
gramys oh my God they're going to lose
their [__] minds absolutely going to
lose their minds and I'm all here for it
I am not going to take the Taylor Swift
shovel out of their hands welcome to the
Tony Michaels podcast as we gear up for
the the Super Bowl who do you have for
the win the San Francisco 49ers or the
Kansas City swifties huh which ones do
you have for the
win who are you rooting
for we're just talking about in The
Producers Corner that these chuds these
maggots these Cheeto humping [__]
nuggets are in a weird situation they're
in a weird situation with this Super
Bowl really [__] weird because
they're like we hate San Francisco look
at all the homeless people in San
Francisco we hate homeless people we
don't want to fix the homeless problem
but we hate homeless people it's kind of
like the Border thing you know they hate
brown people but they don't want to help
fix the problem right they don't want to
actually do anything about it they just
want to [__] about it same way the
homeless problem they don't want to do
anything about it they want to [__]
about it but they [__] hate San
Francisco it's a [__] dump it's it's
a bunch of gay people and homeless
people and it's a liberal City one them
sanctuary liberal cities just a just a
communist commune of a country they
think it's a country probably I would
imagine that a lot of them think San
Francisco is a country
right they got a root for San
Francisco a they [__] hate San
Francisco they [__] hate it they're
basically begging San Francisco please
let us please run us rout for you I know
we said mean stuff about you in the past
what a bunch of dumb [__] Taylor Swift
wins a Grammy last night best album of
the year and she shits in their cereal
when she does her little speech you know
when you win you get to go up and you
get to hold the little [__] thing and
you get to give a speech you know what I
mean at the
Grammys and that she's like oh yeah by
the way [__] dropping a new album in
April you're going to talk about me all
summer long you [__]
maggots ah here here's the timeline
Tony's already calling it that's right
I'm making the prediction we're going to
talk about Taylor Swift up to the Super
Bowl and then probably three to four
weeks after they're going to do nothing
but [__] about what happened at the
Super Bowl you think they're going to
stop talking about Taylor Swift being on
camera at the Super Bowl well you're out
of your mind you haven't learned yet if
you think these these [__] ignorant
right Wingers are gonna stop talking
about Taylor Swift appearing on camera
at the Super Bowl it's 100% gonna happen
they're going to keep bitching about it
and bitching about it and bitching about
it oh she's so famous she's so popular
she's so
talented why does Travis Kelsey like her
so
much it's GNA be great and I'm telling
you we should lean into it we should
lean into the Kansas City swifties
talk there's no way we should back away
from this because by the time we get to
April like they're going to they're
going to talk about her for like three
or four weeks after the Super Bowl we're
into march by then by the time we get to
that point oh everyone's gonna be
talking about her new album being
released in April and they're not gonna
shut up about her until that album's
released once the album's released
they're gonna talk about her all summer
long and I hope they keep talking about
her I hope they never I hope they never
shut up about Taylor Swift
honestly it's the best thing that that's
actually happened to democracy [__] her
in dorsing dark Brandon that ain't the
best thing that Taylor Swift has ever
done for democracy Taylor Swift being a
talented powerful influential young
woman beautiful young woman irritates
them more than her endorsing
anyone that's the irritation to them
that she influences other young
beautiful powerful influential young
women and they're going to make a move
for their rights and they know that's
what they're going to do they're going
to vote they're going to Simply vote for
politicians who will protect women's
rights that's what they're going to do
it's not [__] complicated it really
isn't and they're terrified of her
influence they're terrified of it
because they know the numbers the reason
why the NFL pans to Taylor Swift during
the games is because millions of people
come to watch those games that wouldn't
have watch those games just to get a
glimpse of her in Travis Kel's jersey in
the box next to his mom that's it 30
seconds that they watched the entire
[__] game for 30 seconds to see
Taylor because she means that much to
them she is that much of an influence on
them she is that much of a good role
model that really [__] pisses him off
so I'm all here for it like I'm gonna
lean into this son of a [__] yeah I
know you're going to get tired of
talking about Taylor but you got to
pretend a little bit I've been telling
you this look we got to pretend even
just a little bit even if you don't like
her music be like yeah I love her
[__] music just learn a couple lyrics
to the song just learn a couple songs
that's all you got to do they'll believe
you're a Swifty just like
that again you just gotta pretend a
little bit you know what I mean and I'm
look I'm from Missouri and I'm not a
cheese fan I know this is [__] weird
because almost everyone in the state of
Missouri is a [__] cheese fan but I
was always the one at the [__]
football parties I was the only one that
was willing to root against them so I've
always been kind of like the anti-
Chiefs fan you know what I mean like I
would go I've been to a ton of chiefs
games and I would I would always wear
either the the team's colors that they
were playing or the Raiders colors just
yeah just a [__] with them I've been
I've been causing [__] my entire life
right now [__] with the Chiefs fans
people in Red Hats I'll [__] with Maga
people in Red Hats this is what I do I
guess I don't know maybe it has to do
with the red hat [__] I don't know anywh
who I am now a k City swifties fan
fullon now this you're like but Tony you
got a shirt this is actually it's my
wife's sweater so I had to put her and I
got a red hat on but it's not a Chief's
hat but who cares we're pretending right
we're pretending to be Kansas City
Swifty fans and they're no longer the
Chiefs I actually think that we should
change the name we should get a petition
going to change the name of the Kansas
City Chiefs to the Kansas City swifties
how [__] awesome would that be that
would really P I mean I'm not saying we
get it done you definitely wouldn't get
that done but if you I if you started
that that fod that someone might change
the name of the Kansas City Chiefs to
the Kansas City swifties holy [__] they
would lose their minds even more can you
imagine the amount of videos you know
what we should pretend we should I
should um I should do a little bit of
work here now now that I'm coming up
with this all on my own here on the show
you guys can help me out with this um
maybe we'll get a maybe maybe we'll get
a uh
uh a false narrative alternative facts
maybe we get our own alternative facts
going that yeah they're gonna change the
name they're going to change the name to
the Kansas City swifties apparently
they're considering it if they win the
Super Bowl and Taylor Swift endorses
dark Brandon at halftime and goes fullon
and marries Travis Kelce right after the
game they're going to they're going to
get married live and that's going to um
you
know complete the scop uh and Joe Biden
will become president within a few days
we're not even gonna have the election
you don't you don't need to have the
election when you're going to change the
name of the football team you're going
to have a marriage after the game yeah
it's gonna be officiated by John mad
John
M's John Madden's gonna offic even
though he's dead he's still he's going
to Rise From the Ashes however
wherever John Madden is where JFK Jr is
right that's where he is so he's in this
space where he can come back and you
know what that's a good idea um John
Madden is GNA become the the the
Secretary of football so now that now
that Taylor Swift and the Kansas City
swifties are going to be running part of
our government we're probably going to
need someone who is the Secretary of
football and we can count on John ma
John Madden he's dead but he's not he's
not really dead they they just don't
tell you this stuff you know what I mean
if you would look at qinon in the Deep
part of the internet you would know that
John man's still alive with Michael
Jackson and JFK Jr
so what the [__] you want from me listen
if you don't think that this stuff is
gonna work this stuff is totally gonna
work I know it feels like it's crazy
off-the-wall [__] but I mean they run
around saying Michael Jackson is going
to be the Vice President JFK Jr is going
to be the vice president it sounds dumb
as [__] but it gets a ton of people to
be brainwashed enough to support you
know the sick [__] right so why not make
fun of these people and antagonize them
to say really stupid [__] really stupid
[__] can you imagine if we get Charlie
Kirk and some of these right- Wingers to
have to
debunk debunk a story that they're going
to change the Kansas City Chief's name
to Chan City swifties can you imagine we
bait those [__] into it they
will do three hours three
hours of content on this fake ass story
you see how it works this is how this is
how the [__] kind of works this is
how they [__] with
us they find something that got a kernel
of Truth in it and then they just
completely [__] lie about it and the
left's like oh my God it's so offensive
who and they talk about it talk about it
talk Eminem
and they talk about it but light they
talk about it and talk about it this is
how it
works it's time the tables turn or the
turntables as Michael Scott would say
it's time the turn
tables and we turn it on them we turn it
on
them and we use whatever whatever means
necessary because I'm telling you folks
we're going to win in 2024
the question is how big is the win going
to be and over the weekend you you you
saw
this for the media to pretend for the
last year and a half that black people
don't like Biden you and anyone who
bought that [__] is a dumb [__] is a
dumb [__] it is clear that we need to
stop listening to the media in their
stupid [__]
polls
it is
clear and we need to start listening to
each other and trust each other [__] the
media [__] them and [__] anyone who
wants to pretend to be like the media
[__] them too any I don't care who you
are if you're pretending to be like the
media [__] you
too [__] you
too because there's a lot of news that I
could that I could run laps on but this
one that we can run laps on is Jo Biden
not only went to New Hampshire with a
writing campaign and whipped the [__]
pants off Phillip Philip Dean ain't that
his name Philip Dean is that his name
and then the the the uh the Mary Jane
woman what's her name I don't even know
her [__] name I don't even know these
people Philip Dean is a is a republican
Congressman apparently running for
Democrat he's funded by Haron Hitler
Mary Jane whatever her name is um she's
somehow she's famous because tyt thought
she was famous yeah I know I know know I
know Cindy I'm pretending see I'm
pretending CI pretend [__] them [__]
them pretend like you don't know who
these [__] people are pretend like
they're no nothing pretend like they're
nobodies because they're they are
nobodies and they're backed by big money
to pretend to be someone that they're
not so yeah sometimes sometimes when
you're in a in a hypothetical War
especially a war against misinformation
you may just have to throw them off
their game a bit Wag the Dog when
wag
so Joe Biden goes down to South Carolina
after the writing campaign win in new
New
Hampshire and Joe Biden absolutely I
don't know wins the entire primary like
every [__] last bit of it 90 some
percent it's [__] ridiculous and
Cynthia is right the the the dean
Phillips campaign was only to make Steve
Schmidt money and Steve Schmidt can go
to hell I never I never want to hear him
talk about the democracy and the threat
to democracy and mug [__] [__] Steve
Schmidt [__] him if you ever listen to
him ever again talk prophetically about
the [__] United States and the
stitution just tell him to shut the [__]
up you you don't believe any of that
[__] you're just saying that [__]
try to make money you
[__] [__] sellout sellout
little [__] Steve Schmidt is [__]
him [__]
him so that's that's that's the that's
the story out of the weekend that Donald
Trump now has a new nickname Granda smis
that's right smis has left the bill
building I know I can't keep up with the
[__]
nicknames Joe Biden absolutely destroys
whatever competition they thought he
had in South Carolina and Taylor Swift
scores a touchdown at the Grammys that's
like the that's the
story and and your 401ks have never been
higher and your gasoline has never been
lower put that in comment sections
when you when you hear people bitching
about Taylor Swift just be like yeah but
our 401ks has never been higher and gas
has never been
lower just just write that in just you
might want to just like have it ready
and you just copy and paste that [__]
everywhere everyone's wondering about
smis U
so H Grandpa shitler decided over the
weekend that he was going to compare
himself to Elvis number one Elvis served
our country he didn't have bone spurs
you little
[__] elv was actually I don't know
served his
country he didn't go on deferment
because of bone
spars my my fees hurt my fees
hurt um so that's one comparison the
other one is um Elvis actually had
Talent like he had a real talent
had a real [__] talent but you know
who's counting now there are a lot of
similarities I mean it later in life
Elvis got huge you know huge and tubby
and fat which we all know that Grandpa
smis that's right grandpa smis is the
new
nickname may you know what someone else
came up with smis maybe we should
grandpa smis or Uncle smelvin I'll let
you guys I'll let you guys decide side
grandpa smis or Uncle smelvin you know
what I
mean but Elvis did a ton of drugs too oh
God [__]
[__] Elvis Love prescription drugs they
[__] love he [__] loved him some
goddamn drugs prescribed by doctors and
and so does Grandpa Hitler shitler
Grandpa poopy pants the Cheeto dust Q
honor Uncle Melvis
smelvin Grandpa smis there's so many
[__]
nicknames oh my
God what other news do we have over the
weekend since it's Monday oh yeah you
heard about the clan boy holy [__] it's
not going to surprise you a single bit
the clan boy all the brainless toothless
hillbillies that went down to have a
bigot Carnival at the Children's Ranch
where they where they brought pedophiles
in toe that's right they had a trucker
Convoy that had a bunch of pedophiles
and their destination was not the Border
it was a children's camp they they
brought a bunch of pedophiles to the
children's camp and apparently they were
stealing the food from the children's
camp so they were stealing food from an
orphanage really kind of on brand for
MAA isn't it to go try to demonize brown
people all the while yelling save the
children and putting Children at Risk
with a bunch of pedophiles and then
stealing their food while they're
distracted really on brand for for manga
no I'm serious people are saying what
the [__] are you see yeah I'm [__]
dead serious they were trying to steal
food from the
orphanage and then they were they were
given they were saving people they were
baptizing people in a in a cattle
trough over the weekend too which is
really cool oh yeah I mean I mean when I
was a kid we used to [__] swim in the
C cattle troughs they were you know
bigger ones than what they were using
but we would swim and that was like a
hillbilly hot tub you know what I
mean that's what that is Hillbilly hot
tub but they were they were baptizing
people they they drove all the way down
to the children's camp um bringing along
the pedophiles so they could baptize
people Jesus
Christ no amount of holy water will wash
off the stench of MAA no [__] way no
[__] how not g to happen not a
million years or in a weekend at the
Children's Ranch where they were
stealing food from
orphans why that Grinch he even took
their last can of
who these [__] madit bunch of [__]
Cheeto hump and [__] nuggets aren't
they but we got to stay fast here we
gota we got to stay steady it's going to
be a great week oh my God there's going
to be so much content this week starting
tomorrow of them just absolutely losing
their godamn minds over Taylor it's
gonna start today I mean I'm sure
there's already some content out there
of these [__] you know these white
incels these fragile fascist
men she's so popular why is she so is
it's almost like she's talented and
beautiful and it's almost like she has
empathy for other human beings oh she's
gonna get women to vote we need to stop
women from
voting they're just gonna cry and cry
and cry and cry some more oh another
piece of news I got I oh for all you
people out there that hate when I when I
bash Glenn Glenn two you know Glenn
number two I don't know if it's actually
Glenn kersner if it's Glenn kerner's
like doppelganger I'm not really sure
you think with Glenn kersner would get
the right handle you wouldn't have to
put a [__] two after it but you know
you know Justice matters apparently
social media handles don't he's got a
new video out to tell me how I'm right
that's right I get to run laps with a
Glenn video that's right Glenn kersner
is really confused about why the March
4th trial is is delayed you know who's
not confused you because I've been
telling you the whole time that it's
gonna be delayed like you expected this
because Tony [__] said the truth and
it's gonna be [__] delayed he said he
said that like the day the trial was set
when Chuck and actually set the trial
Tony said that that it wasn't going to
happen that day it's almost like that's
just how it happens every single time in
a federal court it's almost like Glenn
kersner should know this it's almost
like he was a federal prosecutor and
actually he actually was in actual
trials as the prosecuting attorney who
was doing the work of Prosecuting in the
tri it's almost like Glenn Krishner lied
to you it's almost like he did that it's
almost like he did that and I'm gonna
point it out and the reason why I'm
going to point it out is because Glenn
and anyone like Glenn needs to stop
doing that they need to stop lying need
stop bullshitting people to get their
[__] hopes up to get them to keep
watching videos and keep clicking on
[__] come come click on my stuff and
I'll tell you all the stuff that you
want to hear even though none of it's
GNA happen
huh and the problem is is when people do
that with Glenn and and I'm talking to
Glenn here when when Glenn does that
type of [__] or anyone else any other
group of people does that type of [__]
makes pred itions that are just wildly
not even going to be close to what's
going to happen because of just I don't
know
reality what happens is is it it erodes
your credibility see Glenn's credibility
is now eroded and the reason why it's
eroded is because people like me will
point it out and it needs to be pointed
out because Glenn needs to be a little
more responsible rather he's in his own
videos or he's on the The Boob Tube
telling you stupid [__] about stuff that
ain't going to happen it just
ain't it just ain't it never was going
to go down on March 4th it
wasn't I was correct the 14th Amendment
thing not gonna happen not gonna happen
not gonna [__] happen yeah it's it's
great it feels good though but Tony it
feels so good who gives a
[__] and I know I know I'm like yeah
yeah but Tony you say pretend yeah but
you're pretending about a [__]
section of the
Constitution what do you what do you you
know how much easier it is to pretend
about Taylor Swift and to [__] with
these people on Taylor Swift they're
giving you the gifts of a lifetime
they're giving you the gifts of a
lifetime don't let them steal our
narrative away from us don't let the
plot slip from your fingers okay because
with the 14th Amendment and the criminal
trial stuff we risk the plot slipping
away from
us we must have them on defense on Total
Defense this entire
time we must keep them on defense and if
we got to pretend a little bit that we
like Taylor Swift and Taylor Swift is
somehow a scop and we got the email that
she's a scop and we're part of the whole
scop thing fine whatever [__]
them but don't pretend about stuff where
the plot slips through our fingers
that's what they're doing with Taylor
Swift the rightwing is doing with Taylor
Swift what people on the left are doing
with the 14th Amendment that's what
they're doing it's what you're doing
it's the same thing it's the same [__]
it's just the left seems a little more
intellectual because it is usually
leftists are a little more intellectual
that's why I'm here is to kind of dumb
it down a
bit Tony you're so stupid you're not a
lawyer you're not a [__] what the [__]
do you know I got that comment all the
time I got it all the time and don't
worry don't worry the people that are
mad at me about Glenn they're not back
here yet they will be soon but they're
not back here yet it's just us laughing
at
them Tony you're not a lawyer Glenn was
a prosecutor he would know oh really
okay well where's Glenn at where's he
at I'm gonna show you the video today
I'm sorry I just got to run these laps I
gotta run these laps I I can't help it I
just got to run these laps because the
other lap we're going to run soon is the
14th Amendment lap and then the other
lap we're going to run soon is that
Nikki Haley is not going to be the
nominee it is going to be Donald Trump
these things are not hard to see these
things are not hard to know they really
aren't if you just you know get the [__]
out of your
eyes and see what is clear that is going
to happen then we can operate in that
space and we can weaponize whatever we
need to weaponize to win the battle at
the ballot box because that's what we
have to do that is definitely what we
have to do is we have to win this ballot
at the Battle Battle At The Ballot
Box it is so important that we pile
mountains of votes on top of these
[__] just like Biden piled
mountains of votes on top of the two no
names in the Democratic race who think
they got a chance you're done sit down
shut the [__] up it's enough of the
nonsense it's enough of of it it's time
to move on P that [__] and get to
the heart of
this and if you want to talk about the
economic news talk about it say 401ks
have never been higher and gasoline has
never been lower if you want to talk
about the Taylor with this you you say
you goddamn right she's part of the scop
and I'm voting for the scop [__] I'm
voting for The
scop because the Kansas City swifties
are going to win the Super Bowl and Joe
Biden's going to win the Super Bowl
elections [__] it's going to
happen don't go anywhere we'll be right
back speaking of football pizza sounds
really good right
now we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
podcast are you ready for best pizza of
Life bring friends down to pepperoni hug
spot
our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things need delivery
pizzas come fast knock knock who's there
pizza magic eat pepperoni hugs spot
Pizza your tummy say thank you your
mouth say m pepperoni hug spot it's like
family but with more
cheese catch Tony's twitch stream the
[__] list Roundup at twitch.com
tv/ thee Tony Michaels we're back to the
king of Brilliance this is the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast oh welcome back to the
show you know what time it is it's
grifting time are we going to grift we
might as well grift
grifty grift grift grift everyone else
grifts you know what I
mean what do you guys want you what you
want super Griff
gummies super Griff
gummies they don't help they're not
helpful they don't make you healthy they
don't make you feel good um I mean you
can chew on them a little bit they taste
like [__] too but the super Griff
gummies they make us a lot of money when
you buy the super Griff gummies so go to
super Griff G g.
gri and buy your super gri
gummies with the promo code give me your
[__]
money I'm just kidding that's that's not
actual the grift the grift is uh it's
much it's much worse than that way worse
than that it's way worse than that you
just go to the Tony michaels.com that's
right just go to the Tony michaels.com
hit subscribe at the top it is free to
subscribe you pan on down go on down to
memberships this is where I want want
you to get the grift on you can follow
me on patreon for free that's right it's
free to follow I mean you you definitely
should join as a member and a lot of
people are joining as a member and
they're paying their entire membership
by the year which you get 10% off when
you do that which is kind of cool so you
get 10% off your membership if you pay
membership not membership membership I
mean you might take a [__] while you're
doing it who knows you might be on the
toilet while you're uh signing up for a
membership but you can follow me there
for free another place you should go for
free is Discord this is the best grift
on Earth and it is absolutely 100% free
we got a book club in there and we got a
ton of [__] the meme Legion is on the
move that is right the meme legion's on
the move you guys watched as I did a a
meme workshop on Friday when we had AP
on we're talking about the Convoy but we
did a a workshop for making your own
very own Trump memes you can make make
your very own Trump memes with this meme
machine um so go check that video out we
posted it on um on YouTube another great
free gift it doesn't cost you a single
nickel if you're an Amazon Prime user
you just link your Amazon Prime account
to your Twitch account that's right if
you link it you get one free
subscription with your Amazon Prime
account to your Twitch account don't
forget to resubscribe every single month
a lot of people have done that here
recently it doesn't cost you any
anything if you're an Amazon Prime user
all the directions are right here at
this link so it's a free grift too if
you want to give money to a grift you
can either buy me a shot you can send a
vinmo super chat or contribute to the
swear jar but my suggestion is get with
team
tatto that's right two weeks from
Saturday so on the 17th of
February I'm gonna have another tattoo
session that I'll be streaming live from
so if you want to view that just go to
the team tattoo fund we hit our goal we
smashed through the goal last time I
know we'll smash through the goal this
time it's going to be great I'm going to
have fun uh doing the tattoo session
this time because we're going to get
finished up on the microphone part of
the tattoo and then we'll move on to the
Statue of Liberty part of the tattoo
soon so super excited about that if you
want to be part of the tattoo and you
want to be part of Team tattoo just go
to the Tony michaels.com contribute
anything you want to team tattoo there
any amount that you want and you'll be
on the team it doesn't matter I'm not
I'm not going to make you pay a certain
amount if you want to be on the team
just whatever you want you're on the
team I'll get your email and we'll keep
going we'll keep streaming we'll keep
doing
tattoos of microphones that that kill
fascist so all right should we kill some
fashist this morning should we do that
should we do that Taylor Swift is a
psychological operation trust
me John Madden's all in for the scop of
um
of the Kansas City swifties by the way
if you want a picture that's really
gonna [__] piss off maanga boy this
one is one of the ones that you're gonna
want to focus in
on it's got dark Brandon the the uh the
Archangel the Archangel of
antifa the uh the scop herself Taylor
Swift holding the Super Bowl trophy
because that's what she's going to do
not only is she going to deliver um not
only is she going to deliver the Super
Bowl for the Kansas City swifties but
she's also going to deliver the
presidency in the Super Bowl for Joe
Biden um the Kansas City swifties are on
the
move oh my God it's too [__] easy man
it's too easy what do you want from me
how am I supposed
to how am I supposed to operate okay
what should we do what what piece of
news do you guys want to to do first do
you want to do the Taylor Swift thing
since we're already you know balls deep
into the um the Swifty message because I
got a couple things about Taylor Swift
here first off she won a Grammy last
night which I didn't watch the Grammys I
I don't watch the Grammys but I did
watch the clip of her getting up and
giving her speech and pimping her album
for April which thank you Taylor for
that gift that will definitely
definitely live rentree inside the right
winger heads from now until I don't know
probably September when you actually
endorse dark Brandon that's my guess
actually I think she'll probably wait
until
September to endorse Joe Biden because
she's already done it before and
everyone knows she's going to right like
they know she's gonna officially endorse
him and you know in some sort of message
in some sort of way probably encourage
her supporters to register to vote and
go vote for him um you know and the talk
is already there right this idea that
there isn't a Swifty in this country or
on the planet that doesn't know that
Taylor Swift is being attacked by these
right-wing incels is you know there's
not one of them that doesn't know that
not one now one um but she showed up at
the Grammys last night looking
absolutely stunning okay now I think
she's trolling the right wing when she
showed up in this white dress um I think
she trolling them right look at her look
at her absolutely beautiful look at the
stems on this thing good God she's
beautiful and they think
ugly God damn holy
moly and that white dress with the with
the black n I'm no fashion
expert
[__] black gloves dress and how they
have to span it out like it's a um like
it's the like it's a a wedding dress
that's why I think she's
actually she's she's actually trolling
the right Wingers here because they're
all they're all wondering you know is
she just [__] Travis Kelsey or is she
gonna marry him and become his brood may
you know because that's what they'd
really like right is that Taylor Swift
would marry marry Travis Kelce and he
would like make her get Barefoot and get
in the kitchen or some [__] right that's
that's that's probably their wet dream
about
Taylor here course that's probably not
what she's gonna do because she's a very
strong independent woman I didn't
realize she was so tall someone last
night said she was like 5'11 Jesus
Christ look at the legs on this thing oh
my God she's
beautiful I don't know I don't see how
Travis Kelce
wouldn't you know what I mean looking
like Jessica Rabbit and
[__] holy
moly
I I'm just trying to sex it up for you a
little bit you know what I
mean don't call her a thing oh look at
that thing on that thing I listen
whatever it takes whatever it takes to
piss them off whatever it takes to piss
them off you know what I mean I don't
care and really honestly if it if it
takes if it
takes oogling and Googling over her fine
[__] it that's what we'll do that's what
we should do right I mean I actually
think uh she is trolling the right wing
with a white dress here that's her
intention is to make him believe that
she's going to get
married
but it is what it is I mean what are you
gonna do I mean they live rent free it
she lives rent free inside their heads
and really honestly you know I mean [__]
like this they're they're making [__]
like this possible Madden 20205 with
Taylor Swift on it and I'm not going to
lie actually if if if EA sport SPS did
this for Madden
2025 they would probably sell at least
five million more copies of Madden
2025 I don't even know do they even make
the physical copies of games anymore
don't you [__] download it on your
system or some [__] I mean do I sound
old
here and someone who doesn't because I
don't game I don't game the only time I
game is when I'm on Twitch and Skip is
playing the game
you know what I mean and I'm talking
[__] Bo look if they if they actually
did Madden 2025 with her on the
cover they would sell so many more of
these don't you think it's been a long
time since I've played a Madden game
like Madden
03 it's like the last time I played a
Madden game so over like one
tomorrow so but I really do think I
really do think they'd sell five 10
million more copies of this um Madden
2025 if they actually did this cover and
the reason why is because she's so
influential U but there was a video made
over the weekend um let see if I can
find it of a
Swifty who's really upset about Travis
Kelce apparently oh I got an
email I got an email lady video too to
play for you ah [__] we got so much
stuff to do today man I'm going to have
to get with it here because we got to
get to the Convoy we got to get to the
Border Mandel the Border Bill we gotta
get to we got to get to JD Mandel we
gotta get to that um God I got so much
[__] to do today oh man let's see if I
can find this video no that's not it
either son of a [__] son of a
[__] son of a [__] all right we're
gonna move on past the um the Taylor
Swift stuff then uh and we'll move on to
yeah maybe we'll do the JD Mandel stuff
here and then we'll get back to Grandpa
Grandpa shitler and Grandpa smis we'll
get back to that story and then we'll do
the Convoy coming up the
Convoy H we'll do that too oh by the way
one more thing before we go to um U the
next topic Taylor Swift last night
because she won the album of the year
that is four that she has won that is
the record by the way now she is the
[__] record holder for most Grammys
for album of the year most yeah that's a
thing all right let's go to JD Vance
here he was on George
Ste
laus um over the weekend this weekend
with Georgie Porgy and JP Mandel here I
think that's this guy's
name we've endorsed JP
right right JP is that who this guy JD
Mandel oh that's it JD Mandel that's who
this is JD Mandel and George stepanov is
ask him a couple questions here actually
cuts off his mic in the other video but
let's watch this one here let's see if
if JP Mandel oh what's his name JP JD JD
Mandel wants to be Vice pres we've
endorsed JP right JD Mandel so you're
not troubled by the sexualist and
defamation let me ask you about January
6 you've been mentioned as a possible
vice president for Donald Trump had you
been vice president on January 6th would
you have certified the election results
okay number one Donald Trump is not
going to pick a vice president he's not
going to pick a vice president why in
the [__] would a dictator pick a vice
dictator that's not how dictatorship
works by the way he's not going to pick
a vice president but go
ahead oh George this is such a
ridiculous question in part because the
law has changed here uh we of course had
I didn't ask you about going forward I
asked you what you oh George oh Georgie
oh Georgie Porgy Georgie Georgie GE the
law has changed I'm completely ignore
your question all right go ahead I asked
you what you would have George here's
what I think here's here's what I think
happened in 20120 and I know you guys
are obsessed with talking about this I
have to make a point here you constantly
say to people like me why do you talk
about January the 6 why do you talk
about the election of 2020 and then you
ask about us multiple times during a
six-minute interview but look you ask
the question and I'll answer it do I
think there were problems in 2020 yes I
do do I think it was a problem that big
technology companies working with the
intelligence Services censored the
presidential campaign of Donald Trump
yes do I think it's a problem that
Pennsylvania changed its balloting rules
in the middle of the election season in
a way that even some courts in
Pennsylvania have said was illegal yes
okay all right let me tell you all that
[__] he's saying is lies and when it
isn't Lies when he's telling the truth
about Pennsylvania it was Republicans
who changed that [__] law it was it
was it was Republicans cuz before 2020
Republicans were all in on mailing
ballots [__] yeah they were in on
mailing ballots and early voting [__]
they love that [__] they love mailing
ballots until the pandemic made people
realize that maybe we should utilize the
mailing ballots so I could vote you know
but JP JP Mandel here is nothing but a
[__] liar keep going with the lies
you piece of [__] yes I think these were
problems George and I think there is a
political solution to those problems so
litigating which slate of electors was
legitimate I think is fundamentally the
political solution to the problems that
existed in 2020 it's a reasonable debate
to have and I find it weird George that
people like you obsessed with what I
call what happened in 2020 you're so
incurious about what actually happened
in 2020 which is why so many people
mistrust our elections in this country
we've got to I'm not the least bit in
curious in fact you laid out a ly there
but you didn't answer the question I
asked would you have certified the
election results had you been vice
president here's where the treason comes
in if I had been vice president I would
have told the states like Pennsylvania
Georgia and so many others that we
needed to have multiple slates of
electors and I think the US Congress
should have fought over it from there
that is the legitimate way to deal with
an election that a lot of folks
including me think had a lot of problems
in 2020 I think that's what we should
have done oh so he would have been part
of the coup if he would have been vice
president he definitely would have
attempted a coup for Donald Trump smell
this Uncle smelvin Grant Paul shitler he
definitely 100% would have helped him
commit a coup you treasonous piece of
[__] trash you piece of [__] [__]
huh I wonder what else JP Mandell has to
say about I don't know maybe the Supreme
Court a constitution Constitution
stitution you know what what when you're
going to overturn a [__] government
as the hypothetical vice president that
JP Mandel wanted to be he does even know
his [__] name he didn't know his name
and people think they're gonna he's
gonna pick this [__] as his Vice
President are you f are you [__]
[__] me that's what you're G to tell
me that Donald Trump when he was
endorsing him for US Senate didn't know
what his [__] name was and now he's
going to make him the vice president of
the United Kingdom of trump huh get the
[__] out of here with this nonsense get
the [__] out of here with this [__]
it needs to be our number one goal in
that race in Ohio when this son of a
[__] has to rerun that we dunk his ass
in the [__] trash for this comment he
makes right here listen to this [__] 15
years the Constitution also says the
president must abide by legitimate
Supreme Court rulings doesn't
it the Constitution says that the
Supreme Court can make rulings but if
the Supreme Court and look I hope that
they would not do this but if the
Supreme Court said the president of the
United States can't fire a general that
would be an illegitimate ruling and the
president has to have Article 2
prerogative under the Constitution to
actually run the military as he sees fit
this is just basic constitutional
legitimacy you're talking about a
hypothetical where the Supreme Court
tries to run the military I don't think
that's going to happen George but if I
don't think that's going to happen
George see we want project 2025 and we
want Trump to be the king and dictator
this is Project 2025 stuff if you're
listening that's right if you've been
hearing about project 2025 they're going
to start bragging about
it they're gonna start bragging about it
right out in the open and they're going
to be calling it project 2025 and
they're going to be like yeah baby this
is what we want we want to get rid of
every single civil servant that's not
that's not a [__] siant to Trump
every last one of them and not only
we're going to fire him we'll probably
March him off the camp and kill
them that that that's what happened in
Germany when they did project 30
1933 okay same
[__] project 1933 is the same as project
2025 it's just
our project
1933 this the [__] that that that JD
Vance is talking about that the
president United States has the right to
ignore a Supreme Court
decision has the right to ignore
him
especially when it comes to instituting
Nazi Germany style policies to our
democracy now they're going to give us
this gift folks they're going to give us
this gift because basically JD Vance is
saying well if a president wants to be a
king then he can shred the Constitution
so does that mean that Joe Biden can
shred the Constitution does that mean
because Joe Biden is the
commanderin-chief and he has the
absolute Authority over the [__] over
the the dod that even a court decision
even if when he federalizes these
National Guardsmen that are going down
to the
border and and Republicans try to sue
him doesn't that mean they're Hypocrites
here a't that what that means that Joe
Biden really is the king of
America he's the king of
America he's the absolute [__] king
of America Joe Biden is by maa's
definition I mean he's the rightful so
Soul holder of the office of President
of the United States and we all know
that the president has full immunity
from anything he can even try to kill
his political opponents with SEAL Team
Six so that means Joe Biden is the king
of the United
States okay by maa's definition by JD
Vance's
definition
right JD
Mandel so JD JP whatever the [__] his
name is Mandel here if he wants to shred
the Constitution well okay go for it
buddy have to respond to it there are
multiple examples throughout American
history of the president doing just that
you didn't say military in your answer
and you've made it very clear you
believe the president can defy the
Supreme Court senator thanks for your
time this morning no no no no round T's
up next we'll be right
back did you notice that George George
Stephanopoulos is like uhuh you
treasonous piece of trash nahh not on my
show [__] more the media needs to do
this okay more the media needs to do
what George stefanopoulos just said and
if you didn't if you didn't catch what
George just did watch again Watch what
he does to JP Mandel here military I
don't think that's going to happen
George but of course if it did the Pres
president would have to respond to it
there are multiple examples throughout
American history of the president doing
just that you didn't say military in
your answer and you made it very clear
you believe the president can defy the
Supreme Court Senator thanks for your
time this morning no no no no Round
Table's up next we'll be right
back and JP Mandel's
like more of the media needs to do this
every single last time they start saying
treason as [__] they start talking about
shredding the Constitution making Donald
Trump the [__] dictator and King
start start start side side hustling the
project
2025 our project 20 our project
1933 right because that's what it is
Project
2025 is our times Germany's project
1933 it's what it
is and they're going to be bragging
about it as Trump goes to South Carolina
and K KS Nikki Haley in that primary
Marches On to March 5th super Tuesday
because he's not going to be in a
[__] courtroom like I [__] said he
wasn't and he's gonna go on he's gonna
win every single last [__] one of
those primaries every last one of them
he's gonna
win every last one of
them and they're going to stand there
and going to say you goddamn right you
goddamn right want project
2025 we want to clean out the
Liberals in our government so that way
we can ship people off the camps and do
whatever we want Deport people who I
don't know just by the way they look or
what their names are we can Deport them
get rid of them you can't Deport him
then we'll put him in I don't know we'll
put them in ovens or some sort of gas
chamber or some [__] I don't know it's
happened in history maybe it'll happen
again
they're going to say the
[__] and they're going to keep saying it
so what we have to do is keep
stoking the maanga civil war against
each
other and that's the key here is to keep
to keep [__] with them don't ever
stop jacking with these
[__] um here's here's some um
project 2025 because they really they do
they want they want an Empire right they
don't want a republic right that's all
[__] that's all projection we're
Republic not a democracy what they
really want is an Empire I think that
what Trump should do like if I was
giving him one piece of advice fire
every single mid-level bureaucrat every
civil servant in the administrative
State replace them with our people and
when the courts cuz you will get taken
to court and then when the court courts
stop you stand before the country like
Andrew Jackson did and say the chief
justice has made his ruling now let him
enforce
it security and continuing
stability the Republic will be
reorganized
[Music]
into
for and
secure
Society
H and they still don't know they're the
baddies they still don't know see here's
Shaz the the one of the
the the lieutenants of the shart Army
project 2025 hell yeah hey hey Shaz
project 2025 you'll you'll probably be
in a camp
buddy like I mean we've seen your social
media and stuff and um we know the
closet doors are slammed shut
but once those closet doors open
baby man it's going to be a wild ride
for you with project 2025 because
they're not just gonna stop it like
government dude that's not how the Nazis
did it with project 1933 I don't know if
just you know open up a
book that maybe you need to learn how to
read a bit it's all right you can go
back and read history you read out you
read out work there then with fascism
and
dictatorship in Project
1933 go see how that turned out go check
it out man it's a really good
story Kimberly said maggots don't
read Cheeto humping Buck
nuggets
Cheeto humping [__] nuggets well
speaking of Cheeto hump and [__] nuggets
and white Christian
Nationalist and we have this guy named
Dusty ders have you heard of this guy
Dusty
divers down in
Oklahoma um he's just he's just the guy
I've been looking for to show you what
the [__] I've been talking about look at
this and is that Authority
prescribed in the scriptures and we
would say yes God
prescribes uh Servants of his to govern
as his mediators in this on this Earth
Congress
shall
resp Rel when you impose laws on people
who are not Christians right uh they are
Godless let's say they could even be
pagans or atheists and they are now
forced because they live in a
jurisdiction uh like your own let's say
if they pass some of the laws that youve
proposed that um requires them to abide
at least externally under God's law in
some way uh is is that an extension of
the mediatorial role of Christ or um how
how does that work is that something
separate in your mind
Congress you got to use a children's
song to talk to these people at this
point because they just don't clearly
understand it you do not have the
freedom to press your religion on to me
you [__] Nazi okay you do not have
the right to press your religion and
force me to believe what the [__] you
want me to believe that's my [__]
Liberty not yours the freedom listen
this is [__] this is novel it's like
this has never been said on this show
every single time we open for the intro
the freedom to oppress the right of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] I even got [__] shirts I
think somewhere that say this [__] don't
I I'm pretty sure I got a shirt that
says this [__] uh let's see do I yeah
here here's the shirt the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] this is white CHR nationalism this
is the threat I've been telling you
about
folks and it's playing right
into project
2025 and it's exactly what JP Mandel
Senator JP Mandel that's his name isn't
it is that his name I don't know I lost
track JD JP JD
Mandel the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is not Liberty you
should eatting [__] even John Madden
knows even John Madden knows that the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] any
[__]
duh
duh but how are you gonna convince these
morons of that well good luck Jesus
Christ a bunch of these white Christian
nationalists went down to the border
with the pedophiles in
tow in to they went to the Border but
they actually went to a children's camp
did you know that they went to a
children's
camp I could even make this [__] up even
if I
tried the trucker's Convoy decided
they'd go down and have a bigot carnival
at a children's Ranch here it is here's
the video from the bigot
Carnival
Carnival second chronicles 7:14 yes
they're preaching they're preaching
repent I will second chronicles
7:14 2 Chronicles 7:14 repent yes
they're preaching they're preaching
repent
repent they were baptizing people in a
in a goddamn horse trough well that's a
cattle trough where I come from we
didn't have [__] horses right we had
cattle troughs here here here's them
baptizing this was their big their big
thing they did at the border was baptize
white people let me ask you do you think
these people are so Christian that they
would make sure to baptize people coming
across the border that are looking for a
better
life bless them with God's blessing to
come to America and prosper and find
generational wealth um through American
prosperity and American experiment you
think they would you think they would uh
you think they would baptize those brown
women and children coming across the
border to you know to bless them with
God's gifts that they want to be America
you think they would do that huh what do
you think or you think they'd shoot him
huh what do you think I mean they're
cheering these people to be drowned in
water from razor wire so what makes what
makes me believe that they wouldn't want
to shoot him you know bullets for Christ
for crying out loud I'm not talking
about you know Murder here anything I
mean these are bullets for Christ that
doesn't count everyone knows that
if you kill brown people in the name of
Jesus it's not really
murder but they'll baptize a bunch of
[__] redneck white
people that brought pedophiles to a
Children's Ranch
listen they they fooled people into
thinking they were going to go down to
the border right that's that they fooled
every they didn't actually go to the
Border they brought a a bunch of
pedophiles with them and they went to a
children's orphanage called a Children's
Ranch near a
river that it was it was like 400 yards
from the
border and they decided to and they
decided to [__] baptize white people
right and steal the children's food they
stole the children's food let me show
you the baptism first here
well let's play the [__] sound why
not why we're not
Christians at all we pretend to be
Christian even though we're
not look at this yeah Jesus yeah Jesus
this Jesus that blah blah blah yakety
[__] SCH smacky right these people
claim to be right and [__] what the [__]
Jesus Jesus would say Tear Down the Wall
welcome across the border and we'll
baptize all of them in our [__]
cattle troughs that's what Jesus would
do that's what [__] Jesus would do
Dum
Dums Jesus would would would make the
Supreme Court and the Pres United States
Tear Down the Wall welcome across the
border and theyd set up thousands of
cattle troughs to [__] and baptize them
to send them into America with God's
with God's gifts to become
American this isn't [__] religion
this is a cult this is [__] cult
activity when you when you can when you
fool people into thinking you're going
to go to the border secure the border
and you you take a bunch of pedophiles
and go to a Children's Ranch so you can
steal their food and baptize people
that's that's not Christianity that's
not relig religion that's a [__] cult
it's a goddamn death cult if you want to
know the
truth no way you can convince me
otherwise I mean most religion is cult
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna I'm an
atheist so I believe
most most religions and they're all
cults but I'm not kidding you when I say
they tried to steal this the children's
food at this
oranage save the children save the
children save the children save the
children
save the children's food so make sure we
can eat it because they don't need it in
hour these this these ladies
uh you
know it's amazing how you would come and
steal food from the pantry of a ranch
they're trying to help children what a
shame what a shame that's why we're here
tonight here in a little bit we're here
to steal food that's why we're here
tonight and you know what's funny about
this if you look down here right here
I know it's hard to see but they still
have the banner that that says February
3 even after the entire internet pointed
that [__] out they still had that
[__] banner
up oh my God what a bunch of [__]
and then so not only did they invite a
bunch of pedopiles with them like yeah
sure we're going to a Children's Ranch
all the pedophiles kick in you know what
I mean they love it down
there but they stole the food from the
kids what the [__] kind of bigot
Carnival is this oh my God it didn't end
well either because they didn't go to
the Border okay they didn't go to the
border and they got in a big scuffle
this morning I guess as they were
leaving here's a video of how the Convoy
is going how it started but here's how
it's going no free speech no guns no
offensive Christians what kind of
conservatives are you oh you're from
California you're not even attack
himan Diego like America doesn't believe
in the
Constitution because you can't if you're
from San Diego proper you can't believe
in the Constitution listen you [__]
chud San Diego is like one of the
reddish [__] sh infested areas in
California okay I'm not from California
I've only been there a couple times but
I know that for crying out loud everyone
in California is like godamn I'm moving
to San Diego because there's no other
big city that'll welcome me because I'm
an
[__] Jesus Christ these [__]
people like your license plate says
California you must be one of them lib
DS you're not one of us from Texas you
wanted all of the people to whatever
let's keep
going yeah let him fight let him fight
yeah yeah Nazis punching nais do it do
it kick his
[Music]
[Applause]
assent you want to go to
jail [__] him [__] her [__] you know
what I
mean oh man I can't get enough of it can
you kick his [__] I'm GNA kick your
ass you violent son of a
[__] the ninja turtle um the Ninja
Turtle Jeep yeah let him fight fight
fight fight fight fight fight this is
what we need need to be
encouraging this is how fascist work by
the
way this is how fascist work it's how
fascism works it's because they think
they're Superior so they want to be more
Superior than the other's Superior and
and then it's not Superior enough
and it's [__] insane it's
[Music]
insanity but they did this all weekend
long where they just totally stepped in
their own narrative and the plot slipped
out from their fingers like the plot
slipping out from the fingers of the
House GOP this
morning apparently the Senate has a deal
now this deal is written by Senator
lenford and this deal gives everything
Republic every wet dream that
Republicans have ever wanted folks is in
this
bill every don't get it twisted every
[__] wet dream that the Republicans
have wanted with migrants are in this
bill and Democrats are pretending that
they'll vote for it and Joe Biden's
pretending that he'll he'll sign it they
don't need to really pretend because
it'll never get to them because they
can't pretend they can't act on it they
can't they can't now just like they
can't admit that this Convoy was a bunch
of [__] here's Mike America I'm not
kidding you Mike America 177
1776 this is a picture of Mike here see
him here with the um the weirdo
pedophile style cowboy hat excuse me I
mean did I say pedophile you know it
happens um this was yesterday in the
evening
6:23 you can see the timestamp here is
when he posted this this is a picture of
him look at all the look at all the cops
and stuff behind him right oh man just
got pulled over by four BP agents two
state troopers and two sheriffs ha
America America America you're already
facing
charges I thought that that that they
weren't doing their jobs and they
weren't stopping people I thought they
weren't you know I thought the borders
were just wide open and it was like the
wild west down there I didn't think
there was any law enforcement within a
100 miles right ain't that right Mike
America you [__]
chud Cheeto humping [__] [__] nuggets
don't even know when they stepped in
their own goddamn
narrative so literally he gets pulled
over by all these people right and he's
like yeah they're not trying to stop
anybody down there they're just letting
them all through they're all coming to
America
Amer stepping on rakes jumping in Bear
traps time and time and time again they
constantly do it constantly I mean
here's a
video apparently of a woman on CNN
admitting part of the country to be here
and some of them even though we are
about a half hour from Eagle Pass have
driven down to Eagle Pass to try to
actually see what's happening at the
border and I've spoken to a number of
people who said that they're a little
surprised by what they're seeing here I
want to play a conversation with a woman
Misty take a listen it was it it's
pretty surreal we actually made it into
Eagle Pass and we went and saw um Shelby
Park um I was able to see some people
actually trying to cross and stop at the
at the wire there so it was it's very
eye opening and so and tell me more
about eye opening is it what you
expected is it better is it worse it's
not what I expected but then again I
don't know what I expected um I can tell
you it's not as bad as what I thought so
that that's kind of eye opening in
itself too oh vote for Brandon it's not
as bad as I thought there's no Invasion
oh by the way the actual invasion was
the goddamn pedophiles that went to the
children's rants that stole their food
that's the actual Invasion oh my God
holy [__] it's a maanga Invasion down at
the
border Jesus [__] Christ how don't
these people even
realize that they're being so goddamn
ridiculous do you think they do you
think they have any
clue there's no
Invasion at the border other than a
bunch of pedophiles
invading a Children's Ranch to steal
their
food
whoosh
whoosh and then of course they're
they're having their border stunt this
morning right now they're fighting over
this [__] right they're really fighting
over this stuff
[Music]
they can't figure out who's supposed to
be for it and who's supposed to be
against it
and so Senator
Lankford is the is the one behind the
bill right this this um border bill as
it were now of course this thing's
complete [__] don't let anyone tell you
don't let the media [__] fool you
into this [__] because the media is
going to take the right-wing talking
point that oh this is a reason bill
because Democrats are for it listen
Democrats are just for it to [__] with
these [__] because they know they're
not going to pass it in the house they
know there's no way that the Republicans
will ever pass this thing in the house
they won't even bring it to the floor
and the reason why is because they have
a dictator they have a
king their party is a bunch of
authoritarians they know they can't
bling bring it to the floor look look
here's here's Steve
scalise tweeting let me be clear the
Senate bill will not receive a vote in
the house here's what people are pushing
this deal aren't telling you of course
he lies it accepts 5,000 illegal
immigrants his words a day and gives
automatic work permits to Asylum
recipients a magnet for more illegal
immigration it really doesn't do either
one of those things because it's a
Republican bill
okay it's Republicans wrote this
thing and it it is a it is a
[__] wet dream for Republicans this
like honestly at any other point in
history Republicans would be tripping
over their [__] donor's money to vote
against this piece of [__]
bill that's right I mean they would be
[__] just salivating can't wait to
[__] vote for this goddamn thing
and they're not going
to of course they're not going to I mean
even Matt gats is
tweeting [__] senator lenford look at
this look at this here's Matt gats
senator lenford says the board of
emergency Authority has been the most
misunderstood or maybe just
misrepresented parts of the
bill some people have said it would mean
5,000 people a day are coming into the
country every
day that is absurd and untrue and Matt
gats just says take the L oh so Matt
gats isn't for border security guess
what guess what folks Democrats
Democrats are the party of border
security
Now Republicans are for open borders can
you believe that Matt gats does not want
to secure the
Border Matt gats is for for open borders
and so is the Republican party so Donald
Trump must be for open borders if they
don't want to pass this bill you see how
I'm pretending a little bit there see
how that works you got to pretend a
little bit you know what I mean you're
gonna have to pretend a little
bit the Republican party is for open
borders holy [__] they had a chance to
secure and close the border and they
won't take it they won't take it
Democrats are willing to get to get
funding for Ukraine and funding for
Israel for border security and de and
and the Republicans want to keep the
borders
open they want to keep the borders open
H man pH have all them illegals come
into our
country that's what Republicans are
doing that's that's what you should do
is say that [__] put that [__] in
comment sections I know it feels sort of
cringey to say [__] that you don't
really think is true but
listen
we're at War for our
democracy and it's high time we fight
like
it it's high time we fight like it and
like some of the others are fighting
fighting like
it like Mr Goldman Mr Goldman let's
listen and they're doing that while
President Biden and secretary my orcus
are trying to solve the problems at the
border they are doing this purely for
political reasons and political gain and
what it is showing right now is that
Republicans especially in the house do
not want to solve the problems that the
American people care
about they just want
power and that is how you handle these
Sun
[__] and again we need to go after
them and continue to go after them and
continue to go after them even if we got
to pretend a little bit that they're the
party for open borders who cares they
are really if you think about it they
are now they are now aren't they they're
the ones that are walking away from a
deal I mean Jesus Christ even chip Roy
is going to war with Matt gats even chip
Roy is going to war with Matt gats on
this look at this they're the manga
Civil War come at me and call me a rhino
you can kiss my ass look I spent a
lifetime fighting for limited government
conservatism I have laid it all on the
line not seen my family but for two days
in the last 30 days you go around
talking your big game and you thump in
your chest on Twitter yeah come to my
office to come have a debate mother you
know why because I'm standing up for
this country every single
day is it real or is it AI huh could you
tell could you tell if if Chi Roy called
Matt Gat a [__] take a listen to
it again come at me and call me a rhino
you can kiss my ass look I spent a
lifetime fighting for limited government
conservatism I have laid it all on the
line not seen my family but for two days
in the last 30 days you go around
talking your big game and you thumping
your chess on Twitter yeah come to my
office to come have a debate mother you
know why because I'm standing up for
this country every single day come at me
and call me
Rino and he's talking to Matt gats there
I don't know is it real or is it AI or
do you really give a [__] do I give a
[__] not at this point [__] him Let them
fight I don't even care anymore just let
them fight that's the key here is to let
them fight because they're not going to
stop
lying they're not going to stop lying
especially about this border thing sure
as hell not going to stop lying about
this border thing let me show you a clip
of mikro Johnson the wiener of the house
and if I can get a cute up here they're
not GNA stop lying about this [__]
including including gonna stop this bill
from actually coming to a vote
God damn it hang on a
second my [__] is not operating like I
wanted to hang
onits
nits make
way are Matt Gat I got you the underage
girl I got you the underage girl
this a
real oh
boy thanks for the thanks for the fill
in there laboratory from the rat the rat
bastard gave me some filling here's
micro Johnson with his lies about Donald
Trump he said any Republican who votes
for this deal should be ashamed of
themselves you've said you speak to him
frequently and that you've discussed
this deal with him quote at length is
Donald Trump calling the shots here Mr
Speaker of course not he's not calling
the shots liar you're a liar you're a
liar I am calling the shots for the
house that's our responsibility and I
have been saying this far longer than
president Trump has I you know something
that you're not telling us you slimy
scumbag liar I have been saying this far
longer than president Trump has I have
been saying what the requirements are to
fix the problem I don't care if they
call the legislation hr2 or not what
we're saying is you have to stem the
flow
you're a liar you're a liar you know
something that you're not telling us you
slimy scumbag liar what a [__] liar
of course he's a [__] liar why why
wouldn't he lie he's he's a Christian
nationalist Christian nationalist they
lie it's on brand for
them and absolutely 100% without a doubt
Donald Trump is dictating to the
Republican house conference that they
cannot vote for for this bill and the
reason why he's dictating to them that
he and I say dictate on purpose the
reason why he's dictating that they
cannot look look you gotta dict taste
every once in a while you got to dict
taste to these people that's what you
have to do if you want them to do your
bidding you have to dictat to them
that's what you have to
do of course Donald Trump is dictating
orders to Mike Ro Johnson the wiener of
the house and the white Christian
nationalist the maglites in the house
and the reason why is because they need
something to run
on what what are they going to run on if
they can't run on the border they're
gonna run on gas prices being in an
all-time low they're gonna they are they
gonna run on everyone in the country's
401K as high as it's ever been can you
imagine that they're like yeah the
economy sucks so does your 401k and
everyone's like what what my 41 gay has
more money in it than it ever has ever
before
let's go
[Laughter]
Brandon like yeah how do you like them
gas and milk prices and you're like yeah
it's not that bad actually it's way
better than it was two years ago the guy
in charge fixed it apparently I don't
know you said you said Joe Biden needs
to fix the gas prices and
then he fixed the gas
prices so why do you think Donald
Trump's dictating to them that the
Border must be this big huge crisis
that's not actually a crisis there's
actually no crisis at the border you
heard the lady at the Convoy cult thing
right the the Carn the carnival of
bigots she was like yeah there's not
really no one down here was it what I
expected and um there's no one coming
across the border so it doesn't look
like there's a crisis nothing to see
here I wish there was though boy it
really help out my my cognitive
dissidence if it were true
but it's not it's all [__]
lies and it's all lies from this [__]
box Donald Donald smis
Trump that's right he compared himself
to Elvis over the weekend oh I'm gonna
get to that I'm gonna get to that I'm
gonna get to the uncle smelvin here in
just a minute that's he did he compared
himself to
Elvis he think this guy thinks he looks
like this
guy this guy thinks he looks like
Elvis I got news for smis not only does
he not look like does he not look like
Elis but he's not gonna be dictator of
the United Republic of trump either
let's listen and I said I'm going to be
a dictator because he asked me are you
really going to be a dictator I said
absolutely I'm going to be absolutely
abely are you going to be the Absolut I
totally told him I said it look look I'm
going to be a dick taster and I love the
taste I love dick I love it and I can't
wait to taste all the dick on day one
I'm gonna be a dick
taster I mean I I'm not editing this
clip I'm just showing you what he said
listen to and I said I'm going to be a
dictator because he asked me are you
really going to be a dictator I said
absolutely I'm going to be absolutely
absolutely are you going to be
absolutely
ABS he just said this this is not an old
I mean this was yesterday they aired
this [__] yesterday now he's trying to
clean up his his [__] shitty mess his
shitty diaper here right he really [__]
the beted on this dictator one he really
thought that everyone would be like yeah
dictator dictator dictator [__] Joe
Biden and everyone's like dictator
that's the most unamerican thing I've
ever heard anyone ever say in the
history of
ever oh that's un American oh [__] I
gave away the game [__] well [__] I
wanted you to think I look like Elvis
apparently but maybe I look like I don't
know maybe I look like another person in
history it could be possibly because I
definitely I definitely don't look like
Elvis I definitely don't look like well
you
know I mean if John Madden and Elvis
[__] had a baby you know what I mean
oh look at that
diaper good God this is him um this is
him doing karaoke at a um at a wedding
down at Mar Lago I think this is not
this is not AI I promise you this is
real is it real or is it
AI this is real
100% [__] I don't care anymore I don't
give a [__] anymore I don't give shits
anymore but apparently over the weekend
and Grandpa thought that let me let me
pull this up for you I'll show you the
uh the tweet that he or the post that he
put out on fraud social he literally he
literally put this post out um this is
totally real here that he looks like
that he looks like Elvis I'm not kidding
you this is what he says
here so many years people have been
saying people have been saying look
people have been saying I told you
people have been remember last week when
I told Cliff that people have been
saying he got a huge kick out of that
he's like wow I never thought about
weaponizing the [__] that
Republicans do people have been saying
that I look like Elvis and I look like
oh now this pick has been going around
the internet what do you think do you
think I totally don't look like Elvis
because I don't at all look like Elvis
it's totally totally and shows that I
don't look like Elvis I'm going to show
you how I don't look like
Elvis what the [__] well I got I got
news for him I got news for him he kind
of looks like I mean he looks like a guy
from history I'm not gonna lie so I
actually made it a little more truth
year you know what I mean hey you gotta
use the internet you know to bolster the
truth so I went and found this um
screenshot on his account it says for
many years people have been saying
listen listen people have been saying
that Hitler and I look alike now this
pick is going all over the Internet what
do you think what do you think huh do
you think do you think me and the big
guy me and the big guy oh he was the
furer but I want to be the fit and all
furer dick Tas her one day God how I
would love to go back to 1933 and taste
that
dick what I mean it's this is a lot
closer than Elvis right hell a lot
closer than
Elvis oh the things the internet can do
oh the things the internet can do they
can do it can do wild stuff but no he
really he really does believe because
people are saying that he looks like
Elvis so
people people started calling him
smous oh man I don't know maybe there is
a resemblance H especially there at the
end when he was sweaty and fat and
Aderall ridden you know what I
mean smelter
Skelter oh my god oh let's take stop and
take a
minute oh boy this this smelter
Skelter
H remember how I taught you to make
memes on Friday please someone go make a
[__] meme would you please someone go
make a [__]
meme oh boy oh boy uh now here's maybe a
better
representation of
of of Grandpa Grandpa smis here I don't
know this one actually looks more like
um this might be offensive to uh to
Wilbur this one could be offensive to
Wilbur rushy says I'm famous now yeah
smelter
Skelter oh we're using that [__] we're
using that [__] baby for something we're
using
that but this one seems like a little
more a little closer but this could be
an insult to um to
Wilbur you know Wilbur ain't that the
name of
the the pig's name Charlotte's Web and
it Wilbur
wiber
will I don't know maybe I'm wrong could
be um I think there's a popular game for
this though if we're looking for
likenesses Ain there a popular game for
this I thought there was it kind of
gained popularity and then lost and then
came back I think there's a game for
this let's see let's check in let's see
is there a game for trying to figure out
what what Donald Trump looks like who's
that
[Music]
Pokemon and it's true they're destroying
the blood of our country that's what
they're doing they're destroying our
country yeah yeah
Pokemon
Pokemon I don't know I think this is
pretty accurate here of Donald Trump him
and the little
piggy because he is a [__] pig ain't
he what a [__] pig okay let's see I
want to show you an interview though
actually you know what I don't want to
get off this smis thing yet uh
more more smelter Skelter
here causing smelter skel look at that
[__] God damn look at that front butt
woo baby did Elvis have a front butt
like that or is that a full diaper
is that a front butt or a full diaper I
don't know I'm not really
sure God damn holy holy moly bat H holy
front butt
Batman smelter
Skelter
whoosh
whoosh all right maybe we'll move on or
maybe
not maybe maybe not maybe not here here
we we'll play this one maybe I can't I
can't stop the the smell was the through
a body in the county jail the pron B was
there that be to whale B was jumping and
the joint begin swing you should have
heard this knock down jail bird sing
let's
rock hey
is he gonna sing the Jail House
Rock maybe maybe Grandpa smis will sing
the Jailhouse Rock you think he will I
don't I don't know I mean smell us
good oh my
God I'm looking for more of them oh you
know what here's another here's another
likeness uh that he looks like the
Kool-Aid guy remember the Kool-Aid guy
oh yeah the Kool-Aid guy oh yeah he's
got some similarities the difference
between Donald Trump and Jim Jones is
that Trump would charge you for the
[__]
Kool-Aid I don't know maybe we're on to
something there Jim Jim Jones the
Kool-Aid guy I think people are saying
people are saying my Kool-Aid is much
better than Jim Jones Jim Jones's
Kool-Aid just wasn't poisonous enough so
much so that he couldn't charge for it
it was free Kool-Aid
it was free he gave it away he couldn't
charge for the Kool-Aid it wasn't good
enough it was so watered down it was so
gross oh my God Trump Kool-Aid so much
better Maga Kool-Aid is where it's at we
have the best flavors ever in the
history of
ever we have redneck Cherry redneck
Cherry is it's gonna it's gonna kill
it's gonna kill people oh my God it's
gonna kill so many that redneck Cherry
Kool-Aid flavor oh my God it's gonna
kill
oh [__] what do you want from me I'm
having fun I'm having
fun oh my
[Music]
God you're if you've already ate today
you're gonna want
to and if you got stuff in your mouth
right now you're you're gonna want to
take a break here because Grandpa smell
this Grandpa's smis apparently
oo oh man grandpa smis is not having a
good time holy [__] holy [__]
holy
[__] all right should we move on or
should I show you um that he looks like
an Oompa Loompa this a real picture
apparently whoa dude easy on the bronzer
there holy [__] and what's with the
[__] neck vagina thing what is with
this thing what is he what is he holding
that thing look at that neck vag that
he's got that bald chinny and it looks
like the underside of an old man's nut
sack you know what I mean I don't know
if you ever seen one before but holy
[__] dude lay off the [__] godamn lay
off the spray tan or whatever the hell
it is look at it look how you can tell
they put a [__] a you can tell they
put a goddamn a plastic cap on this some
[__] when they're spraying this on his
face you
see CU he he he closes his eyes he
closes his lips and then they have the
cap going over his ears but see the
earlobe here look at this [__] thing
look at the earlobe the ear earlobe
caught some of the spray paint they were
spraying on this [__] this
morning I'm serious so think about it
think about yeah let me show you the
logistics all right so you got a [__]
you got a cap on right and it goes kind
of like my hat here and they're pulling
it down over his ears you know know what
I mean they're pulling it down over his
[__] ears but they forgot the loes
the lobes are hanging
out I'm serious I'm serious the loaves
are hanging out look how it caught the
[__] spray paint there see that
that's how you know how they're doing it
they're putting a big old [__]
plastic like a shower cap on him and
then they're just spraying him
[Music]
down God damn he looks like a [__]
pump
thaty a [__] jack off a
lantern all right are we done with the
um the shaming maybe maybe not I don't
know I don't know we
could we could be we could not be was
nothing all right one more one more one
more I promise one more Grandpa Grandpa
smell
is oh God damn I'm sorry just having way
too much fun I'm having way too much fun
with Grandpa smel this I can't I can't
[__] stand
it I do want to show you an actual video
of Grandpa smis though this is not
recent this is from many many years ago
and maybe people should have taken a
little bit of um advice I could say or
just a page or two out of barara Baba
baba watas baba waas baba watas Playbook
this is after Trump bankrupted himself
in the early 90s that's right he's not
an actual businessman he's a dummy he
just got handed all kinds of money so he
could run around pretending being
businessman you [__]
maggots you Cheeto humping [__] nuggets
but Barbara Walters really puts him in
his place there um and man if we would
have dunk this [__] [__] box and not
listen to a single word this [__]
idiot said
way back
when so much better I've never seen
press reporting as I have with regard to
me and I hope the general public
understands how inherently dishonest the
press in this country is as a member of
the press let me try to clear up some of
the things which you say are
untrue she's like hold my beer
[__] no obviously this is an old clip
because Grandpa Grandpa's smell this
year doesn't have the if I rewind it
just a bit Grandpa smell was doesn't he
doesn't have the fullon um chin vag yet
you see how his how his neck sack his
neck ball sack hasn't dropped yet you
see that I mean it's starting to he's
starting to develop the old Ball
chinion but it hasn't he hasn't fully
developed his neck jet badge yet he
should really go get gender
reconsignment surgery and take the take
the female genitals off his neck he
looks he looks like a [__] porn star
has got
their you know whatever hanging out of
his [__] shirt but this is before the
neck vag um but here Barbara Walters is
like oh let me hold hold my beer [__]
here we go watch this true my back is an
I worked had a terrific deal that allows
me to come out stronger than ever I see
the deal as a great
Victory being on the verge of bankruptcy
being bailed out by the Banks you
skating on thin ice and almost drowning
oh oh you don't have to you don't have
to say all the facts please don't say
facts facts hurt my feelings please B B
please please Baba waa please please
don't say facts facts hurt my feelings
don't okay keep going that is a that's a
businessman to be admired you say on the
verge of bankruptcy Barbara and you talk
on the verge and you listen to what
people are saying I talk to your
Bankers you listen listen people are
saying and you're listening to what
they're saying okay you're listening to
what PE do you see that there that is so
[__] beautiful is't that so sweet
that when it's turned around on him
listen you're no h excuse me bar B
excuse me excuse me you're listening to
what people are saying and only I can do
that only I'm allowed to listen to what
people are saying and say that it's the
truth what a [__] jerk off and she's
like I talk to your
Bankers [__] I talk to the people who
would know [__] and watch watch
him
respond well that's fine and what do
they say I mean you know depending on
which bank you're talking to what do
they say well I I don't know what the
bankers have said the Plaza is a very
valuable property everybody told me oh
you paid too much you paid too much now
they're all saying what a great deal he
made on Plaza no no one said that
another they not no one said that so
he's like no you're listening what
people are saying and I'm saying that
I'm going to say other things that
people are saying because they're all
lies yes lies thank
you oh my
God I gotta watch it again it's only
like 56 seconds long let's watch it
again I've never seen press reporting as
I have with regard to me and I hope the
general public understands how
inherently dishonest the press in this
country rules as a member of the press
let me try to clear up some of the
things which you say are untr my bankers
and I worked at a terrific deal that
allows me to come out stronger than ever
I see the deal as a great
Victory being on the verge of bankruptcy
being bailed out by the Banks you
skating on thin ice and almost drowning
that is a that's a businessman to be
admired you say on the verge of
bankruptcy Barbara and you talk on the
verge and you listen to what people are
saying I talk to your
Bankers well that's fine and what do
they say I mean you know depending on
which Banker you're talking to what do
they say well I I don't know what the
bankers have said the plaza is a very
valuable property everybody told me oh
you paid too much you paid too much now
they're all saying what a great deal he
made on
Plaza no they're not no they're not
you're fo as [__] [__] this is how you
should treat him this is how they should
treat him to his [__] face this is
how they should treat him in public we
should ostracize this [__] he
should be a goddamn Pariah he shouldn't
even want to appear anywhere in public
or on screen because we will do this to
him and again this is back in
1990 when the [__] idiot went
bankrupt over
casinos he got and we talked about it
last week with with Cliff the
[__] bankrupt casinos
it is
impossible to bankrupt Casino the entire
design of a casino is steal your money
it's like the entire design of
Maga it's the entire design I guess he
figured it out years
later guess he figured it out years
later you know what I mean he finally
figured it out he finally figured it out
some more news over the weekend speaking
of
trump and Grandpa smell this Uncle SM
Melvin Grandpa shitler the Cheeto dust
Qin
honor stand up for truth says an couter
has been right about Trump in the past
I'd love to hear what she what he needs
to do in her opinion to help us take
America back this is what stand up for
the truth
says um now this tweet's quite old but
um it took an couter a while to get
around to um respond to this she
responded just the other day a couple
days ago from a tweet that was she must
have been holding this in her
bookmarks she must been laying in weight
you know what I mean just waiting for it
just waiting for it and I you know I
[__] I when these [__] make me
agree with an couter that piece of [__]
it really does piss me off but you know
I'm gonna show you what an's response
was here an says maybe he could
die and couter when
asked what Trump needs to do in her
opinion to help to help take America
back is maybe he could
die I'm not making that [__] up I wish I
was really honestly I wish I came up
with that [__] um but literally
you gotta agree with her every once in a
while it's hard
but sometimes you got to you got to um
people you don't have to agree with
though you know people you don't have to
agree with let me pull it up you're
gonna hate me oh you're gonna [__]
hate
me Yep this guy this guy is the guy you
don't have agree with every single time
Glenn number two now again I'm not sure
if this is Glenn this is Glenn number
two I'm not sure what happened to the
original Glenn kersner and GL number one
um apparently Justice matters but again
social media handles don't that's why
I'm not um Tony the Tony Michaels 2 or
the Tony Michaels three I'm just the
Tony Michaels like that's my social
media handle and you go to the Tony
michaels.com you can follow me anywhere
on social media at the Tony Michels
because I just captured my handle it's
pretty simple just captur my handle the
same way it is
to guess about what things are going to
happen because they always they always
happen they they always happen like when
a federal trial is is schedule and let's
say let's say there's like a former
president right and while he was the
president he tried to overturn the
government right and he's got like all
these Congress people and these state
representatives and all these [__]
lawyers that lose all their law license
let's say he gets all those people to
help him commit a coup see what I mean
and then and then like the next
administration's like well we don't want
to seem political so what we'll do is
we'll we'll hire a special counsil to
look into that coup matter you know that
you try to overturn the
government so they charged the former
president with some felonies for trying
to overturn the government right because
he probably committed these felonies at
least a grand jury thought that he
committed these felonies right and then
let's say this goes to a jur or a
federal judge in a courtroom and that
judge has got to make a determination of
when this trial is going to happen for
these indictments that the grand jury
has
brought now generally speaking there's a
lot of people that would give commentary
on this some of them are former
prosecutors you know what I mean they're
just they're former prosecutors and some
of them have like prosecuted cases in a
federal court so they would know they
would know that almost never actually
ever in history of ever ever does a
federal trial that is scheduled ever
happen on that day it's kind of funny
you can just go back and look at all of
them there's not that many federal
trials if you want to know the honest
truth in the grand scheme of
things almost 90% of every single
Federal indictment ends up in a plea
deal not in a trial so there's not that
many to even go go look at it'd be like
maybe someone actually participated in a
federal trial before I don't know maybe
maybe maybe as a federal prosecutor and
a lawyer someone might do that someone
might do
that so maybe they would know for a fact
when the judge set the trial that it
wouldn't happen that day that they said
it it's almost like um someone who's not
a
lawyer guy with two fingers
or two thumbs and is not a lawyer this
guy said that it wasn't going to happen
on that very same day that very same day
that judge Chuck and set the March 4th
date I said you can go back and [__]
look at it go back and look at the tape
I said he will not go to trial that day
he will not go to trial that day he will
not he will not go to trial on March 1
4th it won't happen and I've been saying
it every day since every day
I've been saying this guy has been
giving false hope to people when he
knows that it's not the truth that's
right Glenn has been lying to you he
lied to you now he tries to cover up his
lie and anyone else listen to me anyone
else who gave you hope about this was
also [__] lying to you especially if
they're a lawyer listen to me very
clearly if a person said on a YouTube
video that it's for sure for sure for
sure for sure that he's going to be
tried on March 4th and didn't say
there's 100% possibility that he won't
actually be tried on March 4th 100%
possibility 100% And if they're a lawyer
and they said that [__] they were lying
to you they were [__] lying to you
they know better they lawyers they were
[__] lying to
you all right let's hear Glenn's
explanation of why he lied to you given
that the March 4 Federal prosecution in
DC fell off the calendar what does it
mean Donald Trump has a backup auxiliary
prosecution against him the falsifying
business records oh my
God so he's doing it again he's like I
li to you fell fell off the calendar
what it fell off the calendar Glenn what
did that day just oh trip and fall no
it's almost it's almost like he lied to
his [__] listeners to get him to keep
watching videos so they could keep
selling ads to
them listen to me this is why this
pissed me off and I kept talking about
it this is this [__] pisses me
off this guy is not no [__]
dummy he's not a dummy he may be a
chrome dome but he's not a dummy there's
a brain inside that skull
and he's got plenty of [__] brain
cells to rub together to know that he
was [__] lying to you he's not lying
to
maggots he's not lying to Trump
supporters they don't watch his
[__] [__] he probably blocks every
[__] last one of
them every last [__] one of them Glen
kersner should do a video and apologize
to his [__] to his supporters and his
viewers that he misled them he knows he
knows he knows and I'm just trying to
hold him accountable and I know
sometimes that's
uncomfortable I know sometimes it's
uncomfortable I know it's
uncomfortable I know
it trust me everyone tells me not to do
it in the foreground and in the
background they tell me not to do
it but it really really it really does
[__] piss me off when people in our
Coalition are
grifting that pisses me off and that
they're paid to say certain [__] that
they know is not
true that pisses me off it's the same
thing that pisses you off when MSNBC or
anyone on the mainstream media says that
Joe Biden's old No One's Gonna vote for
him he's unpopular black people don't
like Joe
Biden it's all a bunch of [__]
lies it's [__]
lies and we got to smoke out the people
who are [__] lying for a
grift we have to we ha we we got a clean
house on our side or it's not going to
work very well yeah we may win this one
but what about the [__] next
one Jay says do you think he's grifting
Jay listen to me listen to me very
clearly Glen kersner has a contract with
MSNBC okay Glen kersner is paid by MSNBC
Glen kersner could say pretty much
whatever Glenn kersner wanted to now he
may lose his contract with M MSNBC if he
said whatever he wanted to he also has a
very very valuable YouTube channel a
very valuable one where he makes a lot
of money making videos and he makes
videos so that you'll
watch and he likes the Trump crack he
really does Glenn loves the Trump crack
[__] loves
it loves the Trump crack so much he'll
lie to his followers when he says that
it's definitely going to go to trial on
March 4th when he knew it wasn't he knew
it wasn't he's not a dummy he's not
stupid I mean that's the choices here
either either Kushner either Glenn
either knew that this wasn't going to
trial or he was dumb enough to believe
the Del illusion that it was one of the
other one of the other he was never
realistic about it ever and I pick on
him there's plenty others to pick on
right there's plenty others to pick on
there's plenty but we have to call this
out when we see it and I know people are
like you're attacking the left I'm not
attacking the left I'm attacking people
who are taking advantage of the [__]
left it's the same thing I said about
tyt same
[__] same [__]
yeah someone saysi don't think he's dumb
I don't think Glenn's dumb either and
and a lot of people are getting mad and
they're leaving the [__] thing
because I'm I'm oh I like Glenn I like
Glenn Justice matters Tony yeah so does
the [__] truth the truth [__]
matters too it really does the truth
[__] matters doesn't it doesn't it
matter when they're when they're
scraping around [__] about how Biden
isn't popular with black folks he's
losing he's losing the Dem ratic base
and all this
nonsense um happy egg says we don't care
about
kersner I mean when he makes up excuses
about falling off the
calendar it really does feel like we
should care that he's lying to people
and the people are gobbling it up the
Trump crack man oh it's [__] Trump
crack it's all it is that's all he ever
talks about he doesn't talk about the
other
insurrectionist when he's talking about
the 14th Amendment have you ever heard
Glenn talk about another [__]
insurrectionist when he's talking about
the 14th Amendment only Trump only Trump
trump only matters Trump's the only one
that matters the only [__] one that
matters I've never heard Glen talk about
this [__] [__] box Dereck Evans let
me show you something here let me show
you something and show you that Glenn
isn't serious about what he's talking
about he's just making videos so you'll
watch and advertisers or sell the sell
their products here's Derek Evans I'm
the only he said only elected State Rep
to be arrested for the peaceful protest
on January
6 this Derek Evans of of West Virginia
this pick is me in a prison parking lot
as I was released here's old DE Derek
being released from prison with his
prison sweats and his prison
boots he says now I'm running for US
Congress and I'm not running to make
friends he's running to overthrow a
government really I mean he's a [__]
he's a convicted insurrectionist so you
have to assume that right I'm running to
kick in the front door and expose
corrupt DC kick in the front door like
he did on January 6 trary
hostages
why didn't Glenn kersner and I called on
him I [__] tweeted at him about this
this here that Glenn should have equal
opportunity 14th Amendment section three
on Old Derek here I want Glenn to do a
video on
Derek I want Glenn to give a [__] about
this [__] [__]
box I mean if he's goingon to give a
[__] about the 14th
Amendment don't you agree with me or is
it all just Trump crack is it all just
Trump
crack is it is it all just Trump crack I
mean I talk about white Christian
nationalism here on this show more than
probably any other show I show clip
after clip after clip after clip of
[__] white Christian
nationalist the real [__]
threat the real [__] threat to our
goddamn democracy white Christian
nationalism it's the same [__] [__]
boxes that went down to the the the
children's camp and took pedophiles with
them the same people that are trying to
take away women's [__]
rights the same people that storm the
capital try to overthrow our
government I mean look at this
[__] this [__] white
Christian nationalist in Oklahoma Dusty
Dusty ders I showed you a video of him
earlier he wants to criminalize porn and
sexting out of marriage he also wants to
end no fault divorce and support quote
public shaming of those who are at
fault this guy's definitely 100%
addicted to porn and he has definitely
put his hands on a
woman I don't get the clicks and the
likes be because I show their white
Christian nationalist stuff that's not
what I'm trying to
do I'm trying to point the [__] out to
you so you know know what the threat is
so you can go carry that message to
somewhere
else and it's all about messaging
cascading so when Glenn does that
[__] when Glenn does that [__]
that message Cascades that oh we don't
have to worry we don't have to get
engaged the 14th amendment's going to
save us Jack Smith's going to save us
the courts are going to save us there's
nothing we got to do everything's going
to be okay we don't have to actually do
democracy
because then when it doesn't happen when
what what the smart guy former
prosecutor that Glenn kersner says is
going to happen doesn't happen it breeds
discouragement it breeds discouragement
which only causes disengagement in our
democracy and that is something that we
cannot
afford we have to pile mountains of
votes on top of these [__] fascist
pigs whether it's [__] whether it's
Donald Trump or it's dusty divers or
whatever [__] Marjorie Taylor green
Lauren bobert Matt gats whatever [__]
piece of sludge out there that we can
vote against we need to vote against
them because this is the craziness that
they're listening to changes coming in
your news media changes coming in your
governments changes coming in your just
justices Supreme Court justice has oh
great
change change is coming in every part of
your governments changes coming in laws
changes coming in the streets changes
coming in the church changes coming in
your atmospheres change is coming in the
air change is coming in your soil change
is coming in your water change is coming
in your coming in your water what who's
changing why are they coming my
water it can go on and on and on but
this is emails from God
lady and this is the [__] they believe
so we have to [__] stay vigilant
and just because we look at someone on
the left and say you shouldn't do that
[__] you shouldn't be doing that [__] we
look at the media and say you shouldn't
be saying that [__] about Joe Biden now
now that you know what New Hampshire and
South Carolina did shouldn't be saying
that
[__] [__] you we're not going to listen
to
you go to hell go to
hell and if I don't care whatever their
media Outlets independent or not
correspondents
prosecutors I don't give a [__] if they
got a law
degree don't let them fool
you call them out if you have to just
like I call out T tyt just like I call
out David Pacman just like I call out
Glen kersner or even when I call out
Midas Touch I'll do it every single day
all day long because I'm the only one
that can do
it I feel like I'm the only one that can
do it
I mean Jesus Christ people got mad at me
and left today because I talked about
Glenn that's son of a [__] Tony that
[__] he just running lamps
because he was correct I'm not running
lamps because I'm [__]
correct I'm running lamps because I'm
trying to show you what the hell they're
doing to you and how they're trying to
take advantage of your attention
span don't let them take advantage of
your attention span keep your focus keep
your strategic outrage
placed ready directed at the white
Christian
nationalist if we do that if we all do
that in concert and we all participate
in operation go commando we can pile
them under mountains of votes at the end
of this year just like just like Joe
Biden piled Philip Dean and Mary Jane
Mary Jane Williams under mountains of
votes in South Carolina tomorrow same
time same place I promise more [__] FY
100% there's going to be why wouldn't
there be fckery surf up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
[Music]
them hey sh are you excited about the
Super
Bowl Murphy's meor head ass
speaking
and I said I'm going to be a dictator
because he asked me are you really going
to be a dictator I said absolutely I'm
going to be a dictator for one day and I
said I'm going to be a dictator because
he asked me are you really going to be a
dictator I said absolutely I'm going to
be
that